ccsd has been offering free breakfast
and lunch to children at all at schools
across the county but it appears very
few kids are showing up jeremy j ford
joining us live in the newsroom right
now to share what he found out after he
visited several campuses today jeremy
well on tuesday the school district
kicked off its summer food program
providing free in-person meals for
children but turnout appears to be just
a little bit low
i stopped at several schools this
afternoon during lunch
and although it's just three days in i'm
told by some school staff children are
not showing up to eat in the cafeteria
besides the students there for summer
classes i spoke with ccsd communications
manager mauricio marin he explains why
this year the district doesn't have
grab-and-go meals the meals are meant
here to be consumed in our air
conditioned facility and that's to
comply with the guidelines that we get
from the usda now some school staff tell
me they would prefer kids to have the
option to stop by and pick up meals
earlier i reached out on facebook live
asking parents if they're allowing their
kids to eat breakfast or dinner in
person and the majority responded they
would prefer to grab and go while some
parents didn't even know their kids
could eat for free
now i've reached out again to the school
district to see if this would be an
option or if it's going to remain an
in-school option i'm waiting to hear
back and we've also listed the schools
participating in the program and you can
find them on eight 8newsnow.com
reporting from the newsroom jeremy j
ford live
local now